CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
Hi, everyone.
Welcome back to Google
Developers Live.
My name is Claudio.
And I'm one of the engineers in
the Google Drive Developer
Relations team.
As you know, we recently
launched
communities on Google+.
And we have a Google Drive
Developers community where we
have discussions about Google
Drive development, new
features, and anything that
is related to Google Drive
development.
For today's GDL, we asked
members of the community to
ask their questions so that
we could answer them live.
We did that, I think,
the last week.
So we have a number
of questions we
want to answer today.
So let me get started with
the first question.
What I'm showing right now is
the post that one of my
teammates, Steve Bazyl,
published last
week asking for questions.
And let's see.
The first one is from Jeff.
And he actually linked to a
Stack Overflow question.
So let me go to the Stack
Overflow question and see what
the question is like.
The question is about making
a copy of a Google Drive
Template by URL, obviously
using the API,
using the Drive SDK.
I see that this question
was already answered.
Basically, I can just
say that that's an
interesting feature request.
It's not a very common one.
This is probably the first or
second time we get this
feature request.
So at the moment, there is no
way to manage those templates
with the API.
But we will take this together
with the other feature
requests and see
what we can do.
That was pretty easy.
One of my teammates answered.
So let's go back.
Arif [? asks ?]
if there is a layman's
version of how to
set up a static website.
We covered this a lot
in the last weeks.
What we recently launched is a
way for anyone to publish a
static website on
Google Drive.
We think it's very easy.
It is actually targeted not just
to hardcore developers.
But it's also targeted to
advanced users, so maybe
standard users.
It should be very, very
easy to do so.
We have documentation.
But we also have another GDL
recording, from November 29,
called "Google Drive SDK--
Publishing your website on
Google Drive," that explains
how to publish a static
website step by step.
This is not for developers.
We have other GDL--
Google Developers Live--
recordings that show how you
can automate the process.
But if you want the very,
very basic version--
so doing everything from the
UI, not writing any code--
this is what you should watch.
So let me say it again.
"Google Drive SDK--
Publishing your website on
Google Drive." You can find it
on developers.googl
e.com/live/drive.
Or you can go to our
documentation, which is at
developers.google.com/drive.
And search for our
YouTube playlist.
We have a playlist with all
these recordings and all
videos we've recorded
for the Drive SDK.
So you can find this one there,
together with two more
that we did that are
about publishing a
website on Google Drive.
So we have a very basic
one, this one.
We have an advanced one, which
is the one following this.
And we also had a third one last
week that was recorded
with a community member that
wrote his own application that
integrates Hangouts
with Drive.
It's very cool.
You should check that out.
That's two.
And by the way, I love
this community.
Because community members talk
to each other, answer each
other's questions.
So Jeff, the same Jeff who
asked the first question,
replied to this other
question.
And so this channel is not just
for us Googlers to answer
your questions.
But it is also for any of you
to talk to others, compare
your experience and
share your tricks,
answer other questions.
This community is very active.
We're very happy.
We launched it slightly more
than a week ago, I think.
And we have 2,000 members--
more than that.
Then we have a lot of threads.
It's very interesting.
If you're not there, you should
definitely join it if
you're interested.
Then we have Nate saying
two questions.
First one-- "Will Google Drive
and Picasa integrate?" It's a
very good question.
It's a very common
question we get.
And our goal is to provide
users with the best
experience.
And we understand that the
best user experience is
merging Google Drive
with Picasa.
So the short answer is yes.
The long answer is yes,
we're working on it.
And they will eventually
merge.
So we will keep you
updated on this.
Second question--
"How can one obtain public
persistent thumbnail links for
files?" Right now, what you get
in the file metadata is a
short-lived thumbnail link.
So whenever you want the
thumbnail for a file, you
should get the file
metadata first.
And then, check the
thumbnail link.
Because that link might
have changed.
There is no way to get a
persistent thumbnail link for
files from the API.
What we can say is of course,
you can store the
thumbnail on your side.
So you know that the thumbnail
link will expire.
But you go fetch it
the first time.
Fetch the thumbnail.
Store it somewhere
on your side--
or even on Drive, somewhere
on your Drive account.
And then, [? serve ?]
that instead.
I should also remind you that
thumbnails can change.
Because any time, the user that
owns the file can change
the thumbnail, replace
it with a new one.
So that's another reason why
we don't have a static
persistent thumbnail link.
So that we force you
to get a new one.
And if the new one
is changed--
I mean, it's a new one.
Then, you always get it
instead of reusing the
previous one.
But if you don't mind risking
that, you can always download
a file first-- the
thumbnail first--
store it on your side wherever
even on Drive.
And then use it.
Let's see.
Benjamin--
"I would really like the team's
opinion on this," which
I opened here.
He says this is his most-wanted
feature for Drive.
I don't know if it's very clear
from the screenshot.
What he's asking for is a
feature that is available on
Dropbox, which is an
easy way to copy a
public link to the [? doc. ?]
I think the question
is in two parts.
First, is there a way to get a
public link for a doc, for any
file stored in Drive?
And the answer is,
of course, yes.
And other people answered
this thread by
saying, yes, it's possible.
You have to do this,
this, and that.
What he's asking is how to have
an easy way to do that,
like a right click, a single
call, or something else that
makes it very, very easy.
We don't have that.
But we might think about it.
So this is another feature
request we are going to take
into account.
So remember, there is a way
to get a public link.
And if you don't know how to
do it, some other people
answering this thread will
explain how to do it.
And it's basically going back
to publishing a website on
Google Drive.
But for what concerns the easy,
simple, right-click way,
we don't have that.
We might have that in future.
We'll talk more about that.
OK.
Let's see what else.
Jay--
"What's the status
of the Drive API
migrations between accounts?
We need the ability to identify
users shared on a
file in order to replicate
the ACLs."
So let's see.
What's the point here?
I think the context is of Google
Apps domain, where
domain administrators
want to move files
from a user to another.
And right now, with the API,
whenever you share something,
we only address those
users by IDs--
unique IDs--
but not email addresses.
So for most cases,
IDs are fine.
For instance, when you're in
these Google Apps domain
environment, where you can
know the user IDs for all
users in your domain.
And the broader case may have
files shared to several users.
They're not in the domain.
And for those, you're not
getting the email address.
We are still working on this in
the sense that we need to
find the perfect trade-off
between the
functionality and privacy.
So right now, all you
get is the ID.
And that is fine for
most use cases.
For instance, in the Google Apps
domain case, you can use
service accounts.
And I also have a page here in
our Docs that explains how to
perform Google Apps domain-wide
delegation of authority.
So what is explained here?
You can use a service account
as a domain admin to
impersonate other users
in a domain and act
on behalf of them.
This is usually what domain
admins want or need.
For what concerns the broader
case, we're still working on
the trade-off.
So still, this is a common
feature request.
So this is not the first
time we hear about it.
And we have a lot of discussions
about it.
Please bear with
us a bit more.
And we will update you on what
the decision will be.
Just remember this is
a privacy concern.
So we take it really,
really seriously.
Allen--
"Is there a reason/explanation
that Docs that are in a public
folder on Drive aren't
accessible using
googledrive.com?"
I would say no.
Because files that are in a
public folder on Drive are
accessible using the same
website publishing method that
we just mentioned a
few times today.
So let's go back to our Docs.
We have a page dedicated
to publishing
website content on Drive.
The requirements are that you
set the folder as public.
And according to the question,
the folder was public.
So I'm surprised.
And when you do, the folder
metadata will include a field
called webViewLink, which will
give you the base URL for all
files in that folder.
So this is an example.
Assuming that the folder ID is
A1, B2, blah, blah, blah, the
webViewLink will look
like this--
https://googledr
ive.com/host/folderid.
And for instance, if you have
images in that folder, your
full complete URL to the image
will be googledrive.com/
host/folderid/im
ages/kittens.jpg.
So there is a way to publish
files from a public folder.
And they're accessible from
googledrive.com when the
folder is public.
So if I understand the
question correctly--
I mean, the question is probably
not 100% correct.
Because some files
are available.
We also got some other questions
in other threads.
So I also added them here.
One of those is, "Is there
an example tutorial for
integrating Google Drive
and Android?" Yes.
We really, really care about
the Android Developer
community using Google Drive.
And that's why we recently
published a quickstart.
And we also recorded another
GDL video explaining how to
build your first Google Drive
application on Android.
And this is also linked
in this Google+ post.
So if you follow the link, you
will see that we published a
post on our blog, which is
Google Apps Developer blog,
that explains it
very concisely.
But then, it takes you to the
quickstart guide, which is a
step-by-step tutorial that
starts from the very basics--
so the how to set up your
environment, Eclipse, and
everything, and enabling the
Drive API, creating an Android
project, adding the libraries
you need.
There is sample code here.
That's all it takes.
And at the end of the page, if
you don't like reading, you
can also watch this video that
does all the steps for you.
So you can see--
well, it's actually me doing
all of that and explaining
step by step how you can
write your Drive
application on Android.
So we have that.
And it's a very popular page.
A lot of people are watching it
and watching the video and
checking the Docs.
So if you haven't already, you
should check that out.
I think I have a few
more questions.
This one was on Stack
Overflow.
And someone linked it
on our community.
The question is very simple.
"Is it possible to search within
a Google Drive folder
using the Google Drive SDK?"
Yes, it is possible.
And it's very easy.
We have a simple query language
that you can use in
your Google Drive
Get requests.
And this is our page in
the documentation.
It's called Search for Files,
which should be
pretty easy to find.
And we explain all
you can do here.
And we have a lot of examples.
And one of the examples--
it's exactly on how to search
for something that is in a
specific folder.
And it's very easy.
The query you have to do--
it's folder ID in quotes.
So in this case, if we are
assuming the folder ID is
1234567 in parents.
Parents is the collection of
folders contained in a file.
So when you write this query,
you're saying, I want all
files that are in this folder
with ID 1234567.
MALE SPEAKER: So Claudio, for
those on the live stream,
could you go ahead and
increase the font?
So we can see those
[INAUDIBLE]?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Oh, sure.
OK, sorry about that.
So this is the page I
was talking about.
This is Search for Files.
And so this is how you
search for files
in a specific folder.
And you can combine it with
other search criteria.
So for instance, you can say,
'1234567' in parents.
And title contains 'goodbye.'
You can put that together.
And what that means is they're
searching for all files in
that specific folder with title
containing goodbye.
So this is how we search for
files in a specific folder.
And finally--
let me make this bigger--
I have the last question.
The question is, "What about
enhancing the Share function
on the GDrive mobile app?
Currently, we can only share
files and folders with email
addresses, but the file
remains private.
You can't choose to make
it public, which is not
convenient."
So you can definitely share a
file or a folder with public
using the API.
I will check the mobile app.
I'm not sure that
it's not there.
If it's not, you can always
write your own application
that uses the Drive API.
So remember, with the Drive API
and with the Desktop UI,
you can definitely share
something with public.
I will double check this.
I'm not sure if it's
in there or not.
I didn't check.
But it's a feature we have.
So it's something you
can do with the API.
So if it's not there, we can
probably add it later.
Or you can write your own
application to share something
with the public.
OK, and I think that was the
last question I had for today.
Remember, anytime you have a
question, feel free to write
on the Google+ community
we have.
And if the question is
very technical--
so if you're showing code--
Stack Overflow is even
better for that.
It's the specific
developer-oriented community.
My team and I are always on
Stack Overflow and on the
Google+ community.
So feel free to choose
the one that is
better for your questions.
And if we liked this session, we
can always do more where we
answer your questions live.
And if you want to ask
your questions live,
we can also do that.
Last week, we had a member of
[? the ?] community joining us
to present his application.
So if you want to do that, if
you want to showcase your app,
if you want to talk to
us live, just ask.
We'll be happy to have you on
Google Developers Live.
And with that, I wish to
see you next time.
Remember, we are live every
Monday and Thursday.
But remember, there's also a
lot of contents on Google
Developers Live every
single day.
Thank you.
See you next time.